this Hollywood babble-on with your hosts
Kevin Smith and Ralph Garman this first
email comes from Jacob ziba if that is
his real name Ralph and keV big fan of
Babylon made this little animation from
an old episode hope you enjoy it he did
a great job I wanted to show you this
little animated clip that Jacob put
together because I was very impressed by
his work
I almost didn't show it because
apparently in the process while he was
making it something horrible happened to
the sound and it got slowed down and we
sound very manly in it it's like so go
for so the audio is not great but the
animation is so good I think it wins
that over this is from an old episode
like episode 42 or something we were
talking about the Harry Potter movie
franchise okay and we're talking about
how what a big fan you are and how the
the true magic in these movies is is
love and friendship and family I
disagreed here's a little bit animated
clip from Jacob ziba a friendship and
family and love are the greatest magic
of all yeah that's what those movies are
yeah it is yeah I'd rather have real
magic like [ __ ] magic from Satan yeah
whatever whatever whoever comes from I
don't care that would have been an
amazing series of films it was the exact
same series but every once in a while I
saw him consulting with Lucifer yeah and
he was just like what should we do to
stop Baltimore in Lucifer's like feed me
another babies soul the [ __ ] harry
whips a baby to Lucifer
he's jumping down like an apple and [ __ ]
these are bold aboard on
oh great is that cute that guy's Got
Talent
[Music]